[Music]
[Music]
psychism pants I Kazan tell me more well
we've spent several decades to know
what's the motivation for puns like is
and I think we've spent several decades
now trying to explain consciousness in
terms of completely non conscious
processes in the brain and in my view
have got precisely nowhere with that
project and so what the plan psyche is
proposes is we try and explain complex
forms of consciousness in the human or
animal brain in terms of simpler forms
of consciousness where those simple
forms of consciousness are then
postulated to exist as as basic features
of matter perhaps basic properties of
fundamental particles so it feels a bit
wacky and new-age but you know I think
we should judge a view by its not by its
cultural connotations but by its
explanatory power and I think that the
attraction upon psychism is it it gives
us a way of integrating consciousness
into our scientific picture of the world
and in a way that avoids the deep
difficulties that play the other options
such as materialism or dualism so I
think that in itself gives us a very
least strong reason to take this view
very seriously indeed you talk more
about the one is the fact that physical
science works with a purely quantitative
vocabulary
whereas consciousness is an essentially
qualitative phenomenon simply in the
sense that it involves qualities so if
you think about the redness of a red
experience or the sweet smell of flowers
or the taste of coffee
you simply can't capture these kind of
qualities in the purely quantitative
vocabulary physical science and I think
this was well understood by the the
founder of physical science Galileo so
Galileo only intended physical science
to be a partial description of reality
he hoped that it could capture that the
mathematical features of reality but he
never dreamt it it could capture the
qualities of consciousness which he took
he believed decided in the soul so a lot
of people have this argument I mean a
physical
has done so well you know this ought to
give us great confidence that it'll one
day solve the problem of consciousness
but my responses are when a physical
science has done so well since
specifically because it was never
designed to deal with consciousness so
from the very start
Galileo kicks things off by taking
consciousness outside of the domain of
scientific inquiry and thereby giving
physical scientists I'm all manageable
tasks so I think that's the go I mean
another way of looking at the difficulty
is the clash between the subjective and
the objective
I think physical science tries to give a
completely objective description of
reality as a a description of reality
that could be grasped by anyone no
matter what your life experience so they
might you know there might be aliens who
visit us from another planet and they
have very different sensory organs and
very different kind of experience of the
world and maybe they couldn't understand
our music or our art because of that but
if they're intelligent enough to
understand mathematics they could get
our physics so that's that's what we try
to give it completely as Thomas Nager
put it physics tries to get the view
from nowhere
whereas consciousness is an essentially
subjective phenomenon so you can only
understand someone's consciousness if
you can take on their perspective so a
blind neuroscientist no matter how much
they know about what's going on in the
brain when someone sees colors they'll
never know what it's like to see color
because they can't adopt the perspective
of a sighted person or to use a famous
example again for Thomas Nagel no matter
how much we know about the
neurophysiology of bats we'll never know
what it's like to be a bat because we
can't take on the perspective of a
creature that Ecco locates their way
around the world so I think I mean I
think at the end of the day materialism
always ends up inevitably just denying
the existence of consciousness arguing
that you know there aren't really these
kind of subjective qualities there are
really just the objective quantitative
properties of physical science so I
think yeah that that's really really the
problem with materialism I think
turning to judaism so I take Judaism to
be the view that consciousness is a
property of the immaterial soul outside
of the physical workings of the body and
brain
unfortunately this views hopeless - so I
think we now have I mean I think the
problem is if there was an immaterial
soul interacting with the brain every
second of waking life you know sending
signals to raise our arms and move on
lips that would certainly show up in our
neuroscience there would be all sorts of
things happening in the brain that had
no physical cause there would be like a
poltergeist was playing with the brain
and we just we just don't find that so I
think neuroscience gives us a strong and
ever-growing case that consciousness is
is located in the brain rather than the
soul so this is a problem right so when
I studied philosophy in the dying embers
of the 20th century we were taught that
there were two options on consciousness
right either you think physical science
can't explain it in which case you're a
materialist or oh you think it's
non-physical in which case you're
duelist and I think philosophers have
come to see that you know both of these
options are pretty hopeless and so you
know more and more in the past five ten
years I'd say more and more philosophers
and some neuroscientists are turning to
punt psychism this our best hope for
making progress and consciousness well
as the strongest argument against panic
is it was the thing that you weren't up
against most the weakest argument and
then I'll get to the strongest argument
I think the weakest duggan gates pun
psychism is which is probably the most
common is though it's just weird
just kind of too weird to think the
particles that conscious at all or it's
it's it's got a kind of New Age feel to
it but I mean I just think this really
isn't a serious objection you know
plenty of our best scientific theories
are wildly counter to common-sense the
view the time slows down when you travel
faster the view that particles can be in
an indeterminate between two locations
but I think probably what is generally
agreed to be the strongest argument is
the so-called against plan psychism what
is everything to be the strongest
arguing against plans like is and the
so-called combination problem so this is
the difficulty of how we get from little
conscious things like particles to big
conscious things like brain so this is a
very serious problem and there's a lot
of energy currently being expended to
try and make progress on this there are
people exploring integration of
information people trying to rethink the
nature of spatial relationships or
part-whole relationships some people
three minutes okay maybe I'll get back
of it so that there are people thinking
about the integration of information
people thinking about whether we can
rethink the nature of spatial
relationships or part-whole
relationships people thinking whether we
can think of this is a more general
aspect of the problem of the unity of
consciousness so I think yeah there's
lots of very interesting ideas and
there's real hope that we can make
progress on this so it's not it's not
that pun psychism offers as a complete
finished theory of consciousness you
know I think it's it's still very early
days in the science of consciousness but
to my mind the problems faced by the
pants I guess looked to be much more
tractable than the problems faced by
either the materialist or the dualist
it looks to me just like just looks like
a more promising research program and
and you know it doesn't have to be
either/or
you know sometimes materialist talk as
if we shouldn't be doing anything else
but trying to get a materialist solution
of consciousness and everyone else is
you know holding back scientific
progress but you know we can let a
thousand flowers bloom and you know and
you know see what happens see what see
what can be worked out well I mean fast
question the code I think consciousness
is the realm of possibility and you
can't know about possibilities unless
they're in a conscious space I think
minds are containers of possibility
possibilities are not physical facts
they're just possibilities and they can
only exist in something like an
imagination so I think our conscious
mind so you know that's what they do
they're to do with choices among
possibilities our unconscious minds are
about habits things that we just do
automatically we
need to think about them and I think all
minds really are spaces of possibility
even the mind underlying the cosmos so I
think that think of Minds in general as
conscious spaces or realms or containers
of possibility units on the road there
to pan psychism what do you think
oh I'm propensity ism I just think those
pen psychics don't go far enough
most pen psychics talk about the
consciousness or minds of electrons or
protons or and assumes and things like
that which is fine the reason they do
that is because they're trying to
explain how we come to be conscious
standard materialism is the doctrine
that matters unconscious the whole
universe is unconscious and then they
have the problem okay but everything's
unconscious and everything is made of
matter including our brains how come
we're conscious so they only have said
well the consciousness is somehow
emerges out of complex arrangements but
how can something totally different from
unconscious matter emerge that's called
the hard problem in the philosophy of
mind so to get out of that some pants
cyclists some materialists have become
pen cyclists by saying okay well let's
have a little bit of consciousness in
electrons and atoms and things so
consciousness can emerge from something
it has a much much lower grade of mind
or consciousness even in subatomic
particles and therefore we can overcome
the problem of how something different
in that's it's a difference of degree
not a difference in kind the emergence
of consciousness in human brains so I
think that's fine I don't have a problem
with that but the question I then asked
them is well what about the Sun the Sun
is a self-organizing system what does
the Sun think about what's the mind of
the Sun like I'm personally I think the
sun's conscious and indeed the entire
galaxy and the whole universe so I'm in
favor of pen psychism but pan means
everywhere psyche means mind I'm in
favor of pen sarcasm I just think it's
so
much too limiting to confine it to the
realm of subatomic physics so
consciousness is not an emergent
property of material well emergent
property I mean what does it mean it
means that something comes from
something that wasn't there before it's
a way of conjuring something out of like
a rabbit out of a hat
you see there are three main ways of
thinking about it one is top down the
whole universe is conscious and even
before there was any matter there was
consciousness or mind and the evolution
of matter in the universe is the content
the universe has lower in lower levels
of consciousness as it evolves the Big
Bang the entire universe is one system
one mind as it were then the fields of
physics and things separate art and
stars and galaxies and whatnot so then
you have the emergence of many forms of
consciousness and then on life a life on
Earth you have I dare say in biology
there is an emergence of higher forms of
consciousness I mean we have more than a
worm or a bacterium so in that area in
then you could say that there is a kind
of emergence but the top-down
consciousness means you start with
consciousness and it goes down from the
bar as it were the bottom-up materialist
theory is you start from subatomic
particles and atoms and you work your
way up and then you have to say well it
emerges but you could just as well say
it descends the third position is say
well it's both there's a sense in which
there's a an emergency or an appearance
of high levels of complexed you with
more complexity but it's not that it was
not there before and after all our
evolution has happened within on the
planet Earth within a galaxy and what if
the whole galaxy and what if the whole
solar system are conscious and what if
Gaia the earth is conscious then our
consciousness has appeared within much
larger conscious systems
so you know these are philosophically
different ways of looking at it there's
a prejudice in modern science in favor
of materialism and reductionism and
bottom-up explanations but that's really
a kind of philosophical fashion it's not
the truth
how long is it in the fashion and how
much further think is well it's been the
fashion since the late 19th century's
times became dominated by materialism in
the late 19th century and in many ways
our views of matter have changed since
then they had an old classical physics
view of matters little atoms as little
billiard balls quantum theory changes
that very radically and they didn't know
about the galaxies beyond our own or the
Big Bang or modern cosmology so all
these things have changed but the
philosophy of materialism sorted locked
in a 19th century worldview and of
course you can have an updated
materialism and in a sense Pan cyclists
are trying to update materialism but as
soon as you admit psyche or mind into
matter then it's not really materialism
it's really a form of animism animism is
the belief that the whole of nature is
alive and they hold universes like an
organism not a machine I think that's a
much more reasonable view of myself
so what we're at the moment in is a kind
of conflict between old-style
materialism and the kind of animism
Orpen psychism struggling to get out and
so far it's only got as far as atoms and
molecules but one reason I like to ask
pen scientists about the consciousness
of the Sun is that I think they're on a
slippery slope and I'd like to push them
down it a bit fast and they go on their
own and discussing the consciousness of
the Sun is a very good way of
accelerating this slide down the
slippery slope into a full-blown animism
it seems to be like there's a what was
what was the basic definition
then what is this thing that the
materialists and miss wrapping over well
I mean there's hundreds of definitions
but it's to do with awareness and as I
said to start with possibility I that's
my own definition it's about a realm of
possibility they would say it's about
perception awareness algorithms and the
brain you know as soon as you get into
modern cognitive neuroscience then the
brain is a computer consciousness is
just the software programs running it
but they of course needn't be conscious
in fact they're not conscious so in the
materialist philosophy of mind
consciousness is either an epiphenomenon
that does nothing like a kind of shadow
of physical activity in the brain that
has no role and it has no free well it
doesn't actually do anything that's the
majority of you or else it's an illusion
produced by brains because it might have
some conceivable evolutionary advantage
but it still doesn't do anything the
problem is that to call consciousness an
illusion doesn't explain it it
presupposes it because illusion is
itself a made of consciousness so
philosophers of mind and the materialist
school go round and round in circles
like dogs chasing their tails trying to
explain it never succeed and any one of
them comes up with a theory another one
will point out the flaws and they come
up with their own and the other one will
point out the flaws in it and and that's
why it's called the very existence of
consciousness is called the hard problem
it seems to me one major part of that is
just the limitations of language of word
to adequately describe a phenomena the
way I
being this the hot problem is will show
many things one of it is just how
limited English or languages to describe
them stuff I don't think the problem the
consciousness is a problem of language I
mean language itself of course is a
product of consciousness and languages
inadequate to explain many things
including the ultimate nature of reality
at the beginning of the universe and so
forth but I don't think that the problem
is with language I think the problem is
with worldviews and do you have a
worldview that's essentially an atheist
materialist worldview
there is no God there is no
consciousness out there the universe is
unconscious it's purposeless meaningless
everything's happened by chance or
accident the laws of nature have no
particular reason to be one way or the
other we just live in a universe where
they happen to be right for us
evolution is a matter of blind chance
mutations and blind natural selection
that's a worldview that says that
consciousness has just emerged in our
brains and doesn't actually do anything
also that we don't have free will
a deeply depressing worldview and I
think that when you have whole societies
based on it like ours what you'd predict
is that lots of people would suffer from
depression and the facts actually bear
that out if you think you live in a
meaningless world by your mind is just
in your brain and it's nothing more than
what's happening inside your head not
truly related to anything else deeply
depressing whereas if you think that
consciousness is primary that we live in
a universe that's purposeful that our
minds are part of something much greater
than ourselves that mystical experiences
connect us with greater Minds than our
own they're not just serotonin levels
changing inside our brains but then you
have a completely different view of the
universe it's not just imagine language
pants like is my phone really odd I mean
I I see things that are colored I'm not
tempted to think that means that
fundamental particles must have color I
I see things that are alive but I'm not
tempted to think that therefore some
particles must have the life property
things in aggregate interacting Lots
behave in novel ways compared to how the
parts on their own behave we see that
all the time you see that even in a pile
of sand which will have a you know
characteristic shape of slope and it
when builds up and then there'll be an
avalanche and it will shift back into
that shape it's an emergent property of
lots and lots of grains of sand it's not
a property of any individual grain of
sand
now one walls not tempted to say are but
that means every grain of sand must have
a kind of heat property that it brings
with it to the heap right just the heap
is what you get when you put all the
sand together so why on earth would you
think that you have to say electrons are
consciousness for very very complicated
systems and material things to be
conscious any more than you'd have to
say that you know for there to be
wetness there has to be kind of wet
molecules the things that we perceive
the world to be like might be artifacts
of our interaction with the world that
are experienced and we don't need to
think that the things have those
properties independently of us we need
to understand how given the properties
they have got independently of us
through interaction with us and our
nature our minds we can perceive them to
be in certain ways and that's what we
now think we don't tempted to think that
sweetness as we experience it is in
sugar so I I don't understand why you
wouldn't say the same thing about
consciousness I mean and give you
another example I think that there can
be moral properties but I'm not tend to
say though in order for that to be true
they have to be little good and bad
electrons it's an emergent property of
the world given life and
sentience and the possibility of
suffering and social groups and so on
then we then get morals and there can
still within that frame what you could
say yeah though moral facts this stuff
about what's right and wrong you don't
need to build that into the sort of
foundations of reality at the particle
level do you I mean why
why don't see it's motivated at all what
the right thing to say is that
consciousness is an emergent property
that only arises in as at the moment
living systems but maybe other kinds of
systems we have to be very physically
complicated and we know that life is an
emergent property of very physically
complicated things consciousness isn't
an all-or-nothing thing I think there's
a tendency among these popular debates
that people talk about consciousness but
they don't distinguish sentience
experience consciousness self
consciousness so if I think about a
spider it's got the primitive sentience
it's got perception is it conscious
maybe a bit you know and then you start
thinking about layers and layers and
layers and then you can get the idea of
okay I can sort of understand how there
could be human consciousness arising out
of matter because it doesn't just it's
not like there's just billiard balls and
consciousness there's this incredible
complexity of layer on the layer in
between the two
the there's a historian of ideas Lynne
white who argued toward the late 1960s
he had he wrote a piece called the
historical roots of our ecological
crisis and what he was saying was that
the problem with ecology dates back to
the overcoming of paganism by monotheism
he says you know in a pagan world if the
rocks are alive if the trees are alive
if the rivers have personalities you
can't just take them right you can't
just cut the trees down with impunity if
they have if they're spirits if they're
living things you can't just remove
mountain tops if the mountain is a
sacred webbing being you have to at
least ask a river before you pollute it
right but he says that the problem with
the triumph of monotheism is that what
monotheism does is it reserves all
agency and all life for conscious beings
God and then humans who are in made in
God's image everything else is just dead
matter animals and just use them with
impunity rocks river street who cares
right so I'd like to think about if like
if we are thinking about rocks rivers
trees bacteria mushrooms as animate as
getting stuff done as in some way having
agency and even maybe personality which
is what a lot of Animists teach us that
they have personalities I think I'm a
real a lot harder to say frack the earth
for natural gas if that earth were a
living animate thing and perhaps even
sharing in what we think of it as divine
so that's that's kind of the hope the
hope is to reanimate the landscape I'm
not the first person to do this there
are new materialist philosophers who are
doing this constantly who are sort of
cobbling together different ontology to
see the way that we can think of even
like lead and steel as animate and
certainly that what we call the
landscape as animate
what I'm trying to argue is that we can
use this work to start also tearing down
the concept of divinity is again
enshrining the importance of humanity
and sort of human comfort over
everything else
and would you go as far as seeing
consciousness and in all beings in the
rocks and the rivers right so here's the
thing yeah I guess I could say yes but
then I get worried about consciousness
because consciousness is the thing that
we have is that the the power the
faculty that we've traditionally
reserved for human beings right so I can
see the sort of generosity and saying
look not only are dolphins and dogs and
whales conscious but also rocks and
rivers and trees are conscious particles
or conscious quarks are conscious things
like that
I worry a little bit about the way that
that kind of remakes the whole universe
and the image of the human so I'd like
to talk I guess a little more about them
having like personality or agency which
or our anima see which feels a little
less like it's taking the stuff that
it's supposed to distinguish us and then
seeing ourselves everywhere in the
universe but sure I you know I that's
the position known as Pan psychism right
the idea that everything down to the
level of the quantum has a kind of
consciousness or proto consciousness
yeah I affirm the pants like it's sort
of pants psychic viewpoint as as helpful
and as useful I guess I just I just
worry that it then ends up
re-establishing a kind of chain of being
where photons and electrons have a kind
of proto like primitive consciousness
and then bacteria have like a little
more consciousness and then you know a
little and then you you know work your
way up and you work your way up and
you're right and finally humans have
like serious consciousness where you get
that same establishment of that
hierarchy of being if you're trying to
see consciousness all the way down so
that would be where I would depart from
the pants.i coasts pan psychics
[Music]
what I'm doing as a scientist as I'm
suggesting that well I'm trying to
understand a specific scientific problem
which is for me it's called a hard
problem of consciousness and I'm trying
to think of a theory of reality that
will allow me to solve this hard problem
of consciousness the problem is this we
have a lot of interesting data that
gives us correlations between certain
kinds of brain activity and certain
conscious experiences that we have so
for example we know that if I take a
powerful magnet called a trans Meg a
transcranial magnetic stimulator and
touch it to a part of the skull that's
just next to an area called v4 and if I
inhibit my neural activity in that area
immediately all color will drain from
the left part of my visual world
I'll just see shades of grey I'll still
see color in the right part of the
visual world but not in the left then
you turn off the magnet and color it
comes flowing back in so there's this
very interesting correlation between
interference with neural activity and
income the right hemisphere and loss of
certain kind of conscious experience in
the left visual world we can do that
with motion if I put the stimulator over
an area called v5 I can turn off my
ability to experience motion in the left
visual field and it turns out that in in
the science of you know cognitive
neuroscience we've discovered scores
maybe hundreds of these kinds of
correlations so correlations are the raw
data
this brain activity is correlated with
that conscious experience and of course
correlations are not a theory rooster
crows are correlated with sunrises but
that's not a theory for example does a
rooster crow cause a sunrise well no
that's we would tend to think it might
go the other way but but it's hard to go
from correlations to a genuine theory of
what's causing it you might say well so
for example we know that brain activity
that we can measure with EEG
electroencephalograms we can predict
your choices that you'll make in certain
cases your free will choices
seven seconds before you can tell me
what you're going to choose so here
again brain activity is cleanly
correlated with your experience 7
seconds later of a choice that you're
making so here again we have this
correlation and in this case you might
say well ok here clearly the theory is
the brain activity came first the
experience of feeling like you had a
free will choice came a few seconds
later
so clearly the brain activity had to
cause it and that's too quick
another example the counter example is
if you look at a train station a bunch
of people assemble at the train station
a few minutes later the train appears
did the people coming to the train
station cause the train to appear no
they didn't so even though the
correlation is tight every time a group
of people appears a train appears a few
minutes later is not the case that the
people appearing cause the train to
appear there's some third entity namely
a train schedule as coordinating broke
both so we have to be very very careful
when we have correlations that's not the
same thing as a theory and then the
final example is you might say well look
when you actually take that magnet and
stimulate area before or inhibit it
you're intervening and by intervening we
can actually figure out what's causing
what right so you turn off before color
goes away surely that shows that be for
is the color experience and that's also
to fast if I'm in a virtual reality game
like Grand Theft Auto and I've got a
steering wheel I can say look I can
intervene I can turn the steering wheel
to the left that will make the car turn
to the left therefore the the steering
wheel is real and it really does have an
effect on the real car no it's not
there's again a hidden reality of diodes
and resistors all the circuits that's
mediating this it only we only have the
fiction of intervening and in a fiction
of causality so the problem we have in
the hard problem of consciousness is
this scientists have gotten dozens maybe
hundreds of these tight correlations we
do not have a theory we cannot explain
why neural activity is correlated with
conscious experiences in particular we
can't offer a single consc experience
like say by conscious experience I mean
something really simple like having a
headache experiencing color
the taste of vanilla the theories that
are proposed are basically only believed
by the graduate students of the
professor who proposes them and and no
theory that's been proposed can even
predict or or specify the conditions for
a single experience like the taste of
vanilla so if you think that neural
activity causes the taste of vanilla
precisely what neural activity is
causing the taste of vanilla and how
does it do it no one has any idea or if
they say that neural activity is
identical to the taste of vanilla then
as a scientist I want to say ok tell me
with mathematical precision what exactly
is the math the neural activity that's
identical to vanilla and why is it
identical
I mean it's anybody can say anything you
know I can say the moon is identical to
two blue cheese and just stipulate it
presumably you need to give me some
reason why I should believe in the
identity so they can't specify the
identity and and much less say why the
identity should be plausible so that's
the problem we've got it's it's a really
deep open scientific problem and it's
very personal we all have conscious
experiences we would like to understand
what
and we also we also have brains we'd
like to understand what's happening here
what's these correlations there where do
you stand in relation to pan psyche
asthma then if we if we ended on
physicalism that's the obvious kind of
opposite theory to physical is me so so
pants I could pant psychism is an
interesting theory there are a couple
versions of it and when I talk to
different pants I kists they they will
say no that's not my version so I'll
talk about two different versions of it
that so in one version is more dualist
so an electron really exists and it
really does have physical properties
whether or not it's observed like
position momentum and spin but in
addition it has a unit of consciousness
and when electron and a proton get
together then somehow the unit of
consciousness from the electron and the
unit of conscience from the proton have
to interact to create the consciousness
of you know of the to put their coming
together right into hydrogen say so
that's that's one theory it's dualist
and most scientists don't like dualism
right so so most scientists would just
not even go there if it may you know
it's not that it's wrong it's just that
we try to come up with a simplest theory
so another version of pants psychism
that some people talk about it in some
sense is what you would just say well
what I was already saying that the
fundamental nature of reality just is
consciousness and some pants I kiss that
I've talked with will will say when I
talk about all these conscious agents
the word agent makes it sound like
there's all these selves and
personalities and so forth and and I'm
not trying to imply that I'm just saying
that there are these elementary
perceivers that can have experiences and
take simple actions in the mathematical
model I don't assume that there's a self
I don't assume intelligence problem
solving creativity in memory even but
what I can show mathematically is I can
from the network with these simple
conscious agents I can build networks
that simulate selves that simulate
intelligence that have memories and so
forth
so so that that version if that's what
people mean by pen psychism then then
it's equivalent to what I'm saying but I
like to just call my theory conscious
realism because I want to be very very
clear that I'm saying that consciousness
is fundamental and I'm proposing I mean
I don't know what the truth is I'm just
a scientist I'm just proposing a bold
hypothesis that consciousness of
consciousness is fundamental and it's
real now if that's false it's false
we'll find out but the idea of science
is to be precise and bold so that we can
precisely find out where we're wrong so
I'm making a precise and bull hypothesis
and it's mathematically precise I
published it so any scientist can go out
there and say this is what's wrong with
the mathematics but that's the whole
goal of course I'm probably wrong I
don't think any scientific theory I've
read so far is correct including general
relativity and quantum field theory and
so forth they're brilliant they're
wonderful tools we should study them
they're the best we've got so far and
they're almost surely deeply wrong and
so the same is true of my theory I won't
say it's brilliant but I'll say it's
probably deeply wrong at least as
presents for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you